reenter ville I think very comfortable
are you comfortable
I think I'm comfortable well I just want
you to be comfortable why won't you look
more comfortable than me oh you know
what it is I'm scared to put my shoes on
your couch why I thought you'd get mad
at me
well you get matter what so what
upbringing yeah but if maybe this'll
work wait oh okay there we go
a real easy
hey guys I'm Greg as we said earlier and
I'm Avery Avery from the channel Avery
official right cuz I'm official she's
official she is a talented singer with
really well done videos really
professional and she has a lovely voice
you guys should really check out her
channel you're a doll
thanks so much you're a doll so this is
a breeze first time on the channel and I
thought okay we got to do a warm-up
video then warm-up video try not to
scream while watching this impossible
challenge hard version as this goes you
have to try not to scream and supposedly
this is impossible you're gonna do this
you don't get scared easily right I
don't get scared easily I don't believe
these people it's impossible come on
like I think they're just bluffing
they're just kidding I don't know about
this don't be such a doubter have some
faith I feel like a puppy's gonna pop up
once all the screen yeah like
something's like I'd like a like a dark
puppy enough that would be scary yeah
dark like a dark popular red eyes red
eye red eyes I always think yeah and
like a swastika engrave him piece right
Avery let's do this try not to
strengthen kinda make it loud don't
watch this alone good thing we're doing
I got its red red
Zefram paranormal activity
Wow my options are horrible jump-scares
what is ready the music is all off the
timing looks like you okay
is this a kill I think it's a chew okay
that's just what we made past level one
oh my god alright no service that yeah
that is scary
oh my god okay now it's funny so wasn't
you oh this ate all they trick dies only
I got us oh that's that [ __ ] sucks it's
so true it's so true
Oh
oh he's like creepy looking
yeah yeah it's that was the word it's
like a regular Ginter Angela their
plastic movie he's in like a giant room
this person this person is ratchet like
this
oh you jumped you Jonas oh my god Joe I
god this hole oh they were just trying
to catch me off guard these idiots
well he didn't scream but I didn't
scream what are you watching what did
you think of that um I thought that was
uh thought I'd tried really hard whoever
this person is yeah that was um not as
rewarding as I was hoping it would be
you know what but these fish doesn't
care because they're like I tricked you
with my title I got views yes chef
triggers this is trickery this is
trickery
Wow you said this [ __ ] doesn't care
this damn you're really hot right now
I'm bad because I was expecting you know
something really scary
I'm not scares you one real life what
scares you well what scares me is um
sharks and like I think those scariest
thing like out of using parks you know
when you get chased with chainsaws why
oh you mean like a Halloween ya know
show an amusement park it's changing all
the time every day that is scary and
also sharks are very scary so like
combined like a shark with the chainsaw
would be my nice shirt for the change
you know just like ripping you up with
its teeth and then I would start ripping
you up with its chainsaw like you oh my
god be careful wouldn't you think the
shark would use the chainsaw first to
make it easier to eat the human that
would make sense yeah yeah well surely
it's not you up with it yeah exactly
those are loud kids huh my biggest fears
um tend to be snakes yeah snakes why did
you have a bad experience with a snake
sort of when I was really young I saw
the movie anaconda co-starring Owen
Wilson
my anaconda don't got none unless you
got buns hon car yes also a fact I also
saw a news report once about how a lady
was killed by a snake when she sat down
in the toilet and there was a mysterious
snake in there oh wait up her vagina but
oh that's worse that's worse that's even
smaller Oh oh my god
Oh God man I can just imagine all like
oh I can just imagine that oh my god
that's real you swear you're not making
I'm not making that make went up her
butthole yeah it was you dad yeah kill
him oh she died yeah and that's I so I I
always like look in the toilet to this
day it's been like 20 solid years of
Issa Oh anything in there all right good
to go oh my god I've had a fear not I
didn't know it was a snake I just had a
fear or something going up my vagina but
now like now I'm gonna be scared now I
know my god you shouldn't have told me
because I went I swam in a bathtub with
my goldfish one's my pet goldfish this
is like weeks ago actually and I was
like screaming I was screaming because I
was so scared they wouldn't go up my
vagina like they kept trying to get in I
swear they kept going down and it was so
scary
but now a [ __ ] snake that's so much
worse than a goldfish this is one of the
greatest moments I've ever had on this
show but I'm watching you go off about
things going up they keep that hole in
your vagina was one of most entertaining
things I've just witnessed thank you for
letting me know that my fear is actually
rational and they can actually happen
yeah it can actually happen oh my gosh
you scared to have a vagina it's scared
you think you just enter at any moment
any oh my god everything tries to enter
vagina my Madonna all the time
everything wants to enter saying blood
escapes all the time it's it sucks oh my
god and you just need to have a dick and
just everything's easy we talk to her
like an hour now
before filming did not see any of this
coming this is great thank you oh my god
oh I'm so glad I got all I feel so much
better than that I've gotten yeah I
didn't realize how much like vagina
phobia yeah I do
I really Wow so that I got to talk about
it yeah
it's like therapy yeah ah well guys if
you the channel you can subscribe today
it'll be worth my time and your time
baby Avery official go check out her
channel seriously listen her awesome
voice lovely vocals can you do you sing
at a moment some do you karaoke
I've never done karaoke before you've
never done I'm a singer and I've never
done karaoke would you be nervous I'd be
so nervous you because you feel like
you'd have to be like great I'm a singer
but I like the worst stage fright ever I
think that's why I like it because I get
like really scared I feel like I'm gonna
die but it also is like a thrill it's
probably why I like it yeah it's yeah
doing things are terrifying or fun
anything that gets your heart racing
your blood pumping don't make it you
made sex jokes for like a solid two
years and now I'm like trying to cut
back because sometimes I don't have like
subtle sex strips my sex jokes are like
really big and obvious they're just not
witty anymore oh they're not funny
you're just like wow you sound like a
pervert oh yeah so you need to like take
I mean really comfortable come up oh uh
Avery's also on snapchat she wanted me
to make sure to mention that because it
has revolutionized her life so important
because I get to have a dog filter I
have so many filters if you want to see
me in all my different filters you're
gonna have to follow guarantee for this
because it's a very stupid name and a
baby with three wise Oh lamb but it's
what I'm stuck with so we're some work
of it and she has an Instagram to my
Instagram is Adrian
and my twitter is a real fish 'el damn
you got some photos on here girl you're
learning rocket hey I don't have like a
good theme I don't know all these girls
are there like theme my feet has to be
perfect
did I might as a mess but no I didn't
hear very photogenic oh thank you you
guys are gonna like these photos oh oh
there's a lot of male subscribers yeah
and they're gonna be very happy to check
out your hands on over males
boobs so many moves so many boobs got so
many boobs in the throat